you're being dan who's harry being you  he died he's harry being me correct it  is odd because we were sort of then me  ruben emma have consultancy roles behind  the monitor  and one mustn't tell lies  now i've got to pretend to be  hermione pretending to be bellatrix in a  big rehearsal room where emma basically  did the scene we said okay just show us  how you walk up to the bank teller what  you'd say to him how you'd say it i  hardly think that'll be necessary  it's really weird kind of watching  someone kind of pretend to be used we'd  shoot one version with me as one of the  characters and we shoot another version  with me as another character  the most surprising thing was how  quickly i got emma harry your eyesight  really is awful  you start to look at people in a very  analytical way when you're kind of  studying them